50歲以下
我做為一個醫生
我還不太會分辨
甚至我認為偏頭痛
一般的醫生
在頭痛醫學大概佔一個小時
正確用藥
到底怎麼樣的用法
如果你____的話
我如果是你
但是不能吃到過量
那怎麼樣去定義過量
哪一些警訊 或者症狀
發生的時候就應該要趕快就醫
_____
因為這有兩個疾病
一個就是我們所謂的
您現在看到的是精華版
如果要看到完整版
請點擊資訊欄的專屬連結
加入官方LINE
Hi 大家好
我是宋晏仁宋醫師
歡迎來到初日會客室
今天邀訪的是我多年來
非常尊敬崇拜的學弟
他的 Paper 被引用次數之多
已經成為全球2%頂尖科學家
2024 年 Research.com
他被公佈成為
台灣最佳的神經科學家第一名
所以我今天面對的是
第一名的醫生
來到我們節目
學長好 宋醫師好
實際上我是神經科醫師
那本身我現在是
台北榮民總醫院的副院長
專門負責教研
那我也當陽明醫學院
現在叫做陽交大醫學院的院長
那我後來就比較專注在看頭痛
第一個我們先講說
頭痛為什麼每個醫生都會碰到
因為發生的人真的很多
所以從您的臨床經驗來看
台灣的頭痛患者的實際情況如何
這是一個被低估的健康問題嗎
大概在 50 歲以下
台灣應該有 200 萬人有偏頭痛
偏頭痛的女生
應該至少有 20%
男生大概約略 8%-10%
這個比例大概跟肥胖有點接近
這很高
但是重點是這樣
肥胖很多人還可以撐一下
偏頭痛是失能性的疾病
就是他一旦發作的時候
你幾乎什麼事都不能做
家醫科醫生其實也經常會碰到偏頭痛
可是常常就在我們的處理過程當中
並沒有被深入的了解
或者是被教導
我們應該怎麼處理偏頭痛
一般的醫生大概在
醫學院的教育當中
在頭痛醫學大概佔一個小時
但是未來他實際上見到
非常非常多頭痛的病人
那我們在乎的是偏頭痛
因為偏頭痛大概佔了
我們醫生求診的 80%
我們光推廣這個 就花了很大的功夫
因為大部分的神經科醫師
都喜歡診斷病人為 緊縮型頭痛
我做為一個醫生 我在學頭痛到現在
我還不太會分辨
什麼叫做緊縮型頭痛
什麼叫做偏頭痛
甚至我認為偏頭痛這個字
常常會誤導說
他是不是只偏一邊痛
對 對 對
我只要問幾個問題
我大概就知道他是不是偏頭痛
這個病人他如果 痛的時候要休息
吃止痛藥了 這第一個
第二個就是我在痛的時候
我會痛得覺得光線很刺眼
或者說你覺得暗一點 對你比較好
那第三個就是 你會不會想要吐
所以噁心 怕光 還有休息
這三件事情 有兩件事情是
你就是偏頭痛
這種人台灣大概有 9%
我們大家熟悉的偏頭痛特徵
就是 60% 的人是痛一邊的
痛起來好像像搏動一樣 像敲鼓一樣
蹦蹦蹦蹦
痛起來的時候 你會想坐在那邊
走一下痛一下
這些就是我們講的偏頭痛
那另外一種 預兆型偏頭痛
也就是我犯的那一種
就是在頭痛之前
他會有單側的視野看到閃光
大概持續 20 分鐘
這也是我在書上看到的
我看過所有的描述
但是我不知道他原來是長這個樣子
如此之美麗
真的嗎
是 如此之美麗
所以是一個美麗的預兆
像張大千大師在畫 那個潑墨畫一樣
哇 綠色 藍色
這樣一直潑在那個牆壁上
所以很多人認為像畢卡索
他們畫圖是因為 他們看到了這個預兆
一般的頭痛
我們都講很多什麼緊張型頭痛
但是來門診求診的人
其實 80% 是偏頭痛
對 他大部份都寫他 緊縮型頭痛
因為我也只敢打 緊縮型頭痛
因為打偏頭痛
就感覺好像很高深的診斷
就怕說是不是我誤診了
可不可以我們來談一下這本書
《你可以不頭痛》背後的意思
一般人是如何在
日常生活當中面對頭痛
我們的前提是 已經進入了偏頭痛
我們不要再去想說 我腦子長東西了
那個機會實在太小了
最大原因是遺傳
我們叫複雜性疾病
Complex Disorder
所以它大部分有非常多不同的基因
但是你為什麼會發作
還是有一些誘發因子
我們最常見的誘發因子
實際上就是天氣
天氣
壓力
睡眠
情緒
只有天氣我們是 絕對沒有辦法改變
最近就是頭痛的旺季
因為突然熱一下冷下來
那住在台北市是悲慘的
我做為家醫科 過去常常認為
天氣變化造成的頭痛
常常都是緊張性頭痛
No 這就是偏頭痛
就是偏頭痛
你看我們家醫科
對於頭痛的誤解有多深
為什麼你知道
我們甚至有做過同樣的研究
我們請了醫學系的系主任
現在楊智傑系主任
他就去算了一下說
颱風來的時候頭痛特別多
為什麼 因為颱風來的時候
氣溫變低 而且氣壓變低
所以這病人就頭痛了
所以你看它的影響很大
那另外一個 我覺得很多的病人
應該會發現如果我是女生
我通常月經要來的時候
或月經發生的時候 我的頭痛會很多
這樣就變成跟 荷爾蒙有點關係
很多病人跑來跟我講
我很怕懷孕
因為我怕我懷孕的時候
我頭痛
那我要吃很多的止痛藥
我會傷害我的寶寶
我跟她講說妳放心
為什麼 很簡單
因為她的女性荷爾蒙 會非常高
而且會持續的高
只是等到她生完小孩以後
女性荷爾蒙又掉下來 就開始又頭痛了
媽媽很常來告訴我說
我為什麼又頭痛
是不是我月子沒做好
我就跟她講說應該不是
原因是因為女性荷爾蒙往下掉了
正好一個月掉到底
所以她開始又頭痛了
如果媽媽覺得月子要做好
就要哺乳
因為妳越哺乳的話
女性荷爾蒙會持續高
妳不會頭痛
您在書上有建議大家
開始善用所謂的頭痛日記
來幫你找出病因
為什麼日記很重要
因為大部分的病人
在告訴我們他的不舒服
都是講他上個禮拜的事
但實際上他看我們一次 是三個月
對 因為我們健保的關係
所以他每次都來說
我好了 我不好了
實際上很不可靠
你只要把你的大中小的頭痛
還有頭痛的症狀記錄
那前前後後大概有沒有什麼主要的事件
那我們實際上 看看那個頭痛日記
大概就可以知道你頭痛是怎麼回事
台北榮民總醫院有一個你可以上網去
你可以 Download 一個日記
你就把它記錄下來
假如說我們現在 在你書上裡面講的說
克服頭痛最重要的因素 是規律
這個是什麼意思
這個我在稍微解釋一下
因為我覺得偏頭痛的患者
他是要規律的生活
才比較不容易頭痛
他不管是放鬆 或是緊張
他只要越規律越不會有問題
很多的病人都告訴我
是那一天要考試
有的人是說
那天考試完了以後頭痛
為什麼 他放鬆了
我們的人生本來就是
有壓力有放鬆的日子
但是我們現在希望 他能夠規律
比如說睡眠你是可以規律
運動是可以規律
你如果禮拜四很痛
那你就是禮拜五去運動
把運動當作一個壓力
這樣子你的生活就會 每天都差不多
那你禮拜六禮拜天 不要睡懶覺
就是你睡得太晚 起得太晚
你頭也會痛
到現在為止的研究
都還不確定運動到底為什麼頭痛會好
但是運動頭痛會好
很多病人問我 要做什麼運動
是中度有氧運動
這個運動要有點喘
可以說話 但是不可以唱歌
最好的運動 我覺得就是快走
有一個非常重要的研究
他就去算出來
到底我們要給病人多少的劑量
30 分鐘 一個禮拜三天 要做到三個月
除了剛剛講的
規律生活 有氧運動講完了
正確用藥 到底怎麼樣的用法
分成急性用藥和預防用藥
那我覺得預防用藥是醫生的事
急性用藥是患者自己也要學習
什麼叫急性用藥
就是我吃了這個藥以後
我兩個小時內不痛 或是微痛
就是我可以去上班了
或者是可以去讀書了
我可以做家事了
我可以做我要做的事情
那就要找一個有效的藥
有普拿疼類的 有布洛芬類的
像 EVE 或是台灣的布洛芬
那還有我們的 翠普登類的藥
那這樣的藥你要去試試看
你單吃或是合吃有沒有效
那什麼時候可以吃藥
如果你一個月痛六天以下
特別是四到六天
我覺得我如果是你
我一定會越早吃越好
不要去忍
就在中痛以下 就要趕快吃
但是我如果說 我的頭痛很多
譬如說我一個月痛六到八天以上
那這種很容易因為吃止痛藥效果不佳
或是吃止痛藥太頻繁
會產生藥物過度使用頭痛
這是很痛苦的事情
大家沒有辦法想像
我如果是在吃關節炎的藥
我會越吃關節越痛
這個你沒有辦法想像
但偏頭痛會
也就是你吃普拿疼
或是普拿疼加強錠
所謂加強錠就是 普拿疼再加上咖啡因
像這類型的藥 實際上你越吃
可能你的頭會越痛
但是不能吃到 你講的說過量
那怎麼樣去定義過量
這樣就已經大概過量
這個時候就應該求助醫生 去調整
對 我們現在有一些藥 它效果比較好
另外一個呢 可能你需要加上預防用藥
所以預防用藥有哪一些呢
那些藥都很不幸
都跟偏頭痛無關
它都是被發現有效
譬如說它在治療憂鬱症的時候有效
它在治療癲癇的時候有效
它在治療高血壓的時候有效的
乙型阻斷劑
它甚至還有一些是 治療頭暈有效的藥
因為很巧它把頭痛 也同時治好了
我們就把它借過來用
那另外一類型 就是我頭痛很多的
叫做慢性偏頭痛
一個月痛超過 15 天以上
那這樣的人 我們還有一種預防用藥
就是肉毒桿菌素
以你現在的深入研究
跟這麼多年來的臨床經驗 再回頭來看
偏頭痛發生的原因
它有沒有什麼分子的機轉
是造成偏頭痛的原因
大概在 80 年代
他們想要了解一個 叫做 CGRP 的藥
因為它都在我們的大腦裡頭
有非常多的 這樣的含量
它是一種神經傳導物質
像蛋白質的胜肽
那個時候大概 1980 幾年左右
在澳洲他們做了一個研究
當你有發生偏頭痛的時候
你到醫院去 從你的外頸靜脈抽血
那就發現說 偏頭痛在發作的時候
它真的是升高了
然後證實說 它到底有沒有相關
他們把這個神經傳導物質
就打入患者身體
它誘發有偏頭痛的患者產生偏頭痛
這類型的藥也讓我們特別意外
因為我們的偏頭痛患者
最難纏的 實際上是他們的副作用
如果你有偏頭痛
偏頭痛的患者他會痛嘛
它實際上是一種感覺的放大
他覺得他的脈搏在跳動
實際上脈搏就好好的
他覺得它在跳動
你會怕光 你覺得光線很刺眼
你的視覺被放大
你會怕吵 你的聽覺被放大
他本來就是一個
感覺系統的被放大的患者
那你的副作用也非常多
我們常常 你給他吃什麼藥
他都告訴你 他這個藥吃了會怎樣
但是 CGRP 這類型的藥
它的副作用非常的少
最近有一個研究
偏頭痛在發作之前
有些人有一些症狀
他連頭痛都還沒開始
他就已經有點噁心
已經有點怕光
他發現說這些病人
可以直接就吃這類型的藥
就可以把這個頭痛之前的
這些前驅症狀都拿掉
那撇開這些臨床藥物不談
我們再回到比較通俗的醫學
對於這些常提頭痛的患者來講
飲食營養補充上
有沒有哪一些東西
是可以幫得上忙的
以前廣泛的講 就是 3C 的食物嘛
巧克力 起司 還有柑橘類食物
還有紅酒
我覺得能避就避
在 2021 年
美國的國家衛生院
他們就做了一個研究
他們就是在做 Omega-3 和 Omega-6
他分三組
一組就是控制組
那另外一組就是 只增加 Omega-3
他不管 Omega-6
第三組就是增加 Omega-3
同時減 Omega-6
如果說你增加 Omega-3
你大概可以減少兩天(頭痛)
又減掉了 Omega-6
你可以增加到四天
那大家一定會覺得說
一個月減少兩天到四天 並不多
實際上錯了
我們大部分的藥物 做出來的臨床試驗
也就只有這麼多天而已
那最後一個生活上的問題
喝咖啡跟喝酒 會導致頭痛
喝咖啡我覺得對頭痛是好的
水能載舟亦能覆舟
你看我們大部分很多的藥物
都叫什麼什麼加強錠
實際上就加了 65 個毫克的咖啡因
我在台灣的布洛芬沒效
我要到日本去買 EVE
因為日本的 EVE 加了咖啡因
有人頭痛到了下午 喝一杯咖啡就好了
但是咖啡因不能夠超過 200 毫克
一杯咖啡大概 100 毫克
所以你喝了兩杯
你就很可能 咖啡因造成戒斷症狀
所以戒斷症狀就是說你不喝
你頭就開始痛
哪一些警訊 或者症狀
發生的時候就應該要趕快就醫
第一件事情就是
發生一個大的 而且是突然來的頭痛
這一定要看醫生
而且要往急診室衝
我覺得記住這個
為什麼
因為這有兩個疾病
一個就是我們所謂的
蜘蛛網膜下腔出血
另外一個就是我們 台北榮總非常會做的
叫雷擊式頭痛
大部分是因為 血管收縮症候群造成的
它一分鐘就到達了頂點 而且很痛
那這種通常發生在女生
你 50 歲以後 產生的新的頭痛
頭痛在改變當中
你年輕的時候痛
但是50歲之後開始發生新的型態的痛
我覺得這三個最重要
其他的像話像神經學症狀
對你來講實在太難了
你會不會一邊一手沒力 或是什麼
但大家千萬不要想說 我那樣子一定是
什麼中風了或是什麼的
先去看醫生再說
所以那些神經學症狀
先不要自己去做診斷
趕快找醫生
頭痛跟中風跟腫瘤之間的關聯性
其實沒有那麼高
是非常少的病人會這樣子
有一句話最有趣
就是他們常來看診說
我痛到要中風了
我跟他講說
偏頭痛通常痛得很厲害 也不會中風
很多人認為我腦子 會不會長東西
我覺得這個機會也非常少
大家千萬不要自己嚇自己
有沒有一些其他的
非正規但是可能有效的療法
國外的人通常都是冰敷
那台灣人都是熱敷
那有人按摩
止痛的時候也有效果
我有一個病人 他說他每次在頭痛的時候
他先生去按摩他 某一個穴道
他就會有效
那針灸我相信是有效的
但是針灸 不會那麼方便
對
一般來講要做針灸
當初的研究是 一個禮拜做到三次
但是針灸我覺得 止痛效果是不錯
另外一個中藥有沒有效
我必須要說中藥 也有一些研究
有些是有效的
天麻 鉤藤 黃耆
這些都是有效的
如果您覺得說 這個事情你在做
而且很有效
那就繼續持之以恆
我相信每個人都可以找到
自己不同的治療方式
我們也抓一些 快問快答來
稍微來玩一下
第一題
洗澡不吹頭會頭痛 是真的嗎
會
真的
耳鳴頭暈跟頭痛之間 有相關嗎
非常大的相關
而且我要恭喜你 如果你是耳鳴頭暈
那你把頭痛治好
你耳鳴和頭暈 可能會好得快一點
生理期的頭痛怎麼解決
不要等了 吃藥
令人頭痛的工作
可能真的引發頭痛嗎
會
因為他壓力會增加
哪一些人吃止痛藥 要特別注意
肝臟有問題 不要吃普拿疼類型的藥
腎和胃有問題的人
不要吃 NSAID 類型的藥
為什麼頭痛很難根治
它是一種體質性的事情
所以你很難根治
還有你的人生啊
我常常講說
所以高光時刻過了之後
開始頭痛就減少了
對 沒錯 沒錯
門診中最常碰到的 頭痛迷思是什麼
醫師我腦子是不是長東西
目前最有效的藥物
我覺得應該還是 CGRP 類型的藥物
所以 CGRP 的藥物
現在的商品名有哪一些
有艾久維 恩疼停
它是要神經科醫師 才能處方
30 年的研究當中
什麼樣的發現 最顛覆你的想法
我們可以發現
在血液抽到一些神經傳導物質
我們最近我們用了 微 RNA
也可以來診斷偏頭痛
microRNA
我們去掃了他 所有的 RNA
然後去找到 可能跟這個疾病相關的
那我們給病患抽血
然後他在發作期 他在非發作期
那我們來做這個
到底是哪一個 RNA 造成的
如果只能給頭痛者一句話
你會說什麼
要做頭痛日記
這樣子才可以跟醫生溝通
今天好高興你來跟我們
深談這麼多
我們下次再找時間
好 謝謝
謝謝你